استاذ ساري ماذا تتوقع من زياره بلينكن
المرتقبه اعتقد ان زياره بلينكن هذه قد
تكون مختلفه بدرجه ما عن زياراته الاولى
في الزيارات الاولى كان واضحا تماما ان
بلينكن منخرط في الحرب الاسرائيليه على
قطاع غزه طبعا بوصفه ممثله للاداره
الامريكيه ليس بالضروره ان يكون انخراطا
شخصيا وكلنا نعلم التسريبات التي خرجت عن
زيارته الاولى حينما بدا وكانه يتبنى
الرؤيه الاسرائيليه لتحجير الفلسطينيين من
داخل قطاع غزه وما قيل في ذلك الوقت انه
حاول ان يقنع دولا عربيه باستقبال
الفلسطينيين من داخل قطاع غزه انا اعتقد
ان زيارات بلينكن الاولى يعني كانت زيارات
مزعجه وسيئه ومنحاز بالكامل والمطلق للحرب
العدوانيه الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه ما
يجري الحديث عنه الان الحقيقه وما تعطيه
الاداره الامريكيه من مؤشرات في الاونه
الاخيره هو ان الاداره الامريكيه تحاول ان
تبحث عن مخرج سريع لهذه الحرب العدوانيه
على قطاع غزه انا اعتقد ان الاداره
الامريكيه منذ البدايه اطلقت يد
الاسرائيليين على على الفلسطينيين داخل
قطاع غزه ومنحت بنيامين نتنياهو ومنحت كل
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه السياسيه والعسكريه
من اجل انجاز اهدافها المعلنه للقضاء على
حركه حماس مثلا او تجريدها من سلاحها او
استرداد الاسرى الاسرائيليين لدى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالقوه العسكريه او فرض
الهزيمه والاستسلام على الفلسطينيين داخل
قطاع غزه لكن امام هذا الصمود الاسطوري
الحقيقه لعموم الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه
وامام هذا الاداء للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
واستعصى المقاومه الفلسطينيه واستعصى حركه
حماس على وجه الخصوص على الانكسار انا
اعتقد ان ثم تحولات في موقف الاداره
الامريكيه ليست تحولات بالضروره ان تكون
جذريه او هي تحولات متعارضه مع مبدا الحرب
ولكن اعتقد انها تحولات تكون بنوع من
الاستطلاع السياسي من اجل البحث عن فرصه
لخلق نوع من التحولات في هذه الحرب على
قطاع غزه تنزل الاسرائيليين عن الشجره
وربما تسعى للاحتفاظ بماء الوجه
للاسرائيليين انا اعتقد ان هذا نوع من
التحول ليس تحولا عن الموقف الاسرائيلي
ولكنه بحث عن مخرج افضل ل
او توفير قاعده ما لنقاش سياسي بين مختلف
الاطراف في هذا الوقت